One of the things you should know is that you actually die into your brain.
So one of the things you might wonder is why is,
why is it the death evolved?
It,
it doesn't really make that much sense from a Darwinian perspective,
right?
Because you'd make the presupposition that if you could just stick around and
farther children safe for 250 years,
you'd be doing a lot better job than the poor SAP who only live to be 30 so why
is it that you only live to be 70 and really your,
you know,
your period of fertility is over,
say by the time you're 40 why would that be?
What's the utility of death?
And then you remember,
well,
the environment's always changing,
right?
In this chaotic manner that's represented by the great mother.
Can you change with it?
And the answer to that is yes,
but only to a certain point,
which is why as people age,
they stay tend to become more and more alienated from the current culture,
right?
They've,
they've adopted their position of being say,
which is a word more or less fixed by the time they're 25 or so.
Once their prefrontal cortex matures and then after that the world gets away
from,
they don't have enough biological resources left to constantly undergo new
revolutionary neurological processes.
And part of the reason is this,
you have more neural connections in your brain when you're first born,
then you do for the rest of your life any other time in your life.
And as you learn when you're an infant and as you learn say over the first two
years,
what happens is that there's a plentitude of circuits and they die off leaving
only those circuits that have a function.
And you think about that,
it's kind of a quasi Darwinian process.
And so what that means is that as you mature and become fixed in your form,
you know,
to adopt your personality,
what,
whatever it becomes,
what's happening is that the excess possibility in some sense is being
demolished by experience.
So the Tirana cull aspect of enculturation is something that's real because it
makes you,
in large part what you are.
And you have to understand as well that that's necessary because it's better to
be something in the final analysis.
It's better to be something than to be nothing.
But you know,
we still have residual dreams like those expressed by Peter Pan,
say who's the boy that never wants to grow up because he doesn't want to attain
any final and fixed form.
And it's interesting because in one respect,
as you progress through your life,
you're climbing,
assuming things are going well,
you're climbing to ever new heights.
But on the other hand,
the,
the direction that you're going in constantly narrows as you age.
So there's a real trade off there.
And,
and,
and I think the existential angst that's caused as a consequence of that trade
off is often real.
And I also think that adolescents and early adults feel this most intently,
which is part of the reason why they tend to rebel against social structures in
general.
You know,
the,
whether it's the military industrial complex or the corporate world or
globalization or what have you,
is that you have these large structures that represent the tier radical aspect
of social being.
And,
and it's no wonder that the fact of those structures in genders rebellion,
it should.
On the other hand,
it's also no wonder that structures like that exist because if they didn't
exist,
then people would have no way of interrelating there.
There are social being,
and we would revert back to the sort of hogs,
Ian State of war,
where everybody's arms are around everybody else's throat.
That doesn't mean the payoff is always good.